disney parks have had the Star Tours  rides for many years but it was only a  matter of time before Star Wars got its  own theme park expansion the Star Wars  lands as they're being called are coming  to Florida's Disney World and  California's Disneyland and now we've  gotten our first glance at them /film  grab some of the concept art shown  during ABC's Disneyland at sixty special  you can see ideas for a cantina Street  Market Imperial docking bay and rebel  base and you might just be able to visit  them on your next big family vacations  Disney's Bob Iger said that the star  wars lands will be the biggest park  expansions yet so there's planning to  get excited for even if they have an  announced a grand opening date but if  you want to stay up to date on Disney  star wars and any combination of the two  keep your eye on gamespot